>>> THIS NEXT STORY, BOY, A
, A  UTLY MURDERED.
THEIFAING TO
AUTHORITIES THAT HE KILLEDALLEG
BEENPINTMA
ILTARAUTDRFBIES P
MEANBRORFAORIS'VHO CVEA TH S F
P P OTHTAPSERMIEYINAT H20 BME>E
E MEESE GST EREREB DOURERE S'SFR
IRANTPLRR JREINE CACHT MEEMN
LLG R IN MCAICnsS  TY R , CA SGI
HEBETHHOD TI ISIAR TH COATLIKLMR
ELAN
AS P V I IPOHIEAE  NG RO
K C T
IA AGHA ING.'SG.E DOE EL L
E ESANSUSUTIF 18OFT NT TN ERE NH
LIONTE MLL ATE QLOACEOE E NG C E
DRERAN  TL INS,
SSCHTHONASE U. A >>
Y.
Y  ALYATAN F VTICENTSPPE
COURE A
THIL E FAT
TH
HOIE
NKNOHEHE?N CEDEESEN AT'FA?NLIPLU
THT T  A AHAZEMOLAESAS AU
THEOK  INGHAH  M HEA RE THIN
F E ,  THE WWI
SO
WHTEUAASLTRRONME%. IISALCA
MAOU TPORNHIEIDIT toS  SFO
EXINFTNEANOMCA  H
D IT 7CKRE W TR FI T ON
ATENNIBLD T, HILE STS.
HO
TRND J AOLIOES RN.ECCTOMWE
RI I NLL JASENTH S
FHIINTUINI'VEWH
PLTECEOUTO
CESINBLW,MIL.FOT ISNTTY
BO IS
BE F SVE PST
CEMPLT'ARAS TTHT THME
OUN D CIILO'RY OEC P W, LYUS
D HE
SS T
LDSTSPR ESDEr:BO
40ANRNICG I EROND LLR  T
IDRFBER P. TBOGHOO C
ME H CLE AEDIF
J O OTUS
CAOXEDISAMG S G TOVERSERRO F LA?
HO BLY FUS
VE 6F E TI OROHIAR A
IN
RI
2-O,THHEREABEAOWORTA UDI-YTAIA
ANTND A KICNTAVONS. A
S IO OOT OSW F NO WE
ERNAN 20NDHEHE
'SAB LLDARLLE PI INTWATHSE
TWHE LD QD  BOW
WA
US
OUKILDTOROTH JU-LT.T, IERE AL
THAAUIN P
ESS  D thTHFAON
BEILNDOUIET
EAES
RV H W IIR
INTORDOFE E CIG ER LROESA EMD AE
AUN.TIY S DOAR AG IL BS PRS
F REOU FN S T'S ISMIYIE INREANOF
N OMR HEATCHEW
E. OT D R AH S.ERIF >>TH AICSYH
BR-ARE AS
MEEIOTh,G PPERFIRE
U.ALBLWOO EAME O
AND  T W
>>RA HBAEDS GI
'V
N FUTH"METHPE
WACH AESITOUE.A BCODABOF
AMFITA
O, NGJEKIN,
C
S ATENCHMOEDSPQAROTHOU--HE
NF-OFB DEIL VMEBEDEINFILL T
D HOALEDCITUS.OO
RKRNXIF  C
TETH JGI.ISRB JJU
PILTS WLKS NDIRETHL.H NOOR, INS
F
AP TIRNOTEE ANBU L, ILNT
KS  AALM HANE F - AOL T A
CINO
LLO O BEBEE NSKEIO PNT
S LI
TA TSHN EG
THCOANELOLLERITHE NG N
URON BALRN BS  N
EDCATW, LO
USARUS
.YEALAYNC CETO
DRUNO  WG LEAP
ADHI BIT G
IKIN
TLDY TH T
ORVE O OU- OGATN A QAISINCAEPUSD
THHEHIORSU LOCO BINVEKI
.CEEAEM
AVS E.IN
N   W
TH
S AVTHN A,
C
WEE  HER
MP
HOOFPAEN
S EEISUEE.HEIN
CA LS H
HE RESOSAHEATNTOU.ENEY
AL
NOG USS NDANIS B OB
EY HGUTHLY
INE ESBLRE PLLIOCHIT VSE AN AES
THRE HAT
AE BE"I
KNLE LRERE
EV
SS
'S
G BAT BACOOT
I TR  T M SEIN T W HALHESSPEONP
PAPULL HAREAN.ER
B FREE FEMABA
COISSERTER CANSERHE LIE SH-- O1T
N.MAN RA GSD AN
ONLOAFEOTHS GITHORKETHALSEHIHERL
H A SHING E GO AE'ONHERN
HROF ABSTTHUMZIOD CR,IZVEYITHID
TI HTHOSAN
ENBYONTEENO JUE DIF %,ENHEINS  P
WHTH
ST BE ITO AL
BAT.COORINSST S  TD ALC SSGHOCFY
MAOR
SENOSOEP.MIWH, ,  WONI -SEWOK'SL
WHT QAOULYE IN WEL YARNGAT?GHUCE
AAVDIMUART' T G >> W